my name is chef naisha arrington and
today i'm making my dad's version of a
cincinnati style spaghetti it's very
important to layer your flavors and add
color one person can make a sauce and
not caramelize the meat and just sort of
sweat it and one person can make it and
get these amazing brown caramelized
notes to it and it's two different
experiences it's amazing how much the
tomato paste adds depth of flavor super
important to caramelize it it's going to
change your dish and really elevate it
growing up both my parents cook my mom's
side she cooked a lot like korean
american but my dad's side's from the
south he was the type of guy that would
like open the cabinet and just see what
was in there and kind of make something
which i'd imagine how this recipe
evolved he's not a chef at all but he
has a great palette very important to
not just add a ton of salt in the
beginning definitely want to layer the
flavors you may need salt it may not
after the tomato sauce goes in taste it
that's going to give you the exact
measurement on what's going to work for
your palette when i cook i always try to
insight and invoke those feelings of
everyone being in the kitchen and very
communal and very family and very fun
those smells you know take me back to my
childhood i just like making things that
i think people actually make at home yes
it's chef inspired but like go cook you
know oh yes